MALE SPEAKER: Thanks,
everybody, for joining us
at "Talks at Google."
Today's guest, I'm very
proud to introduce.
Alexis, don't call him
Alex, Ohanian, who has just
published this book, which
you can all get here,
and you should all read.
I had the great opportunity
to read it before it came out,
and I enjoyed it immensely.
I am surprised to see,
however, that we don't believe
in putting the title
on the cover anymore,
so it's on the back.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Who needs
to go with convention?
MALE SPEAKER: Without
their permission.
So thanks very much, Alexis,
for joining us today.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So not to give
away too much of the book,
but I just wanted to
start by asking you
a little bit about a story
that happens early in the book
that I really enjoyed, which
is apparently, when you were
a teenager, you started
out in a CompUSA
pitching software demos to
basically an empty store
for hours at a time.
So tell me a little
bit about that,
and how you think it might have
actually surprisingly prepared
you for what came after?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Well,
I was a teenager
when a buddy of mine Jacob--
shout out, Jacob Winthrop,
was like, hey dude, one
of my childhood friends,
you want a job demoing
software at a CompUSA?
And I was like, sure.
I don't know what
that entails, but it's
going to pay me
like, $10 an hour.
And I'm like, hell, yes.
So I show up, and
on my first day,
he puts me in this little booth.
Actually, you guys
remember what a CompUSA is?
There are probably a lot
of you who have no idea.
It was this amazing store
where you could go and buy
all your computer-related needs.
And they put me
in a little booth.
And it was this company
called [? Sydea ?], which
was one of the many corpses
from the first tech boom.
But at the time, they were
paying us this absurd amount
of money, $10 an hour, to
basically every 30 minutes,
do the same pitch, the
same like, 10 minute pitch,
of whatever software or
hardware we had at the time.
So it'd be like, look
at this amazing mouse.
It is a great mouse.
I remember we played
this one, there
was a Madelaine math--
I think it was a game.
It was one of those point and
click adventure games for kids.
And I practically learned French
at the end of those two months,
because we'd be playing the
same thing over and over again.
But all that's to say for
like, a chubby teenager
to get up in front of an
audience every 30 minutes
and literally have the worst
experience a public speaker
could have, which is
everyone ignoring you--
MALE SPEAKER: Like, worse
than being a stand-up comic.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Right.
You were basically
annoying people
who were just trying to shop.
And they're always looking
over like, god, really?
You just did this
30 minutes ago.
MALE SPEAKER: You were like, the
pre-internet version of spam.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I was a spammer.
Yeah.
I mean, I was, I would
say a step probably
below the dudes who
are always handing out
flyers on New York
street corners.
And I had my little
megaphone and my headset,
and just demoed software.
But it was-- and you
actually put this
very well as we were talking.
I guess it was like,
my 10,000 hours
moment with public speaking.
And it was a great way--
I mean, it's all practice.
Look, anyone you see
up there who's like,
an amazing public speaker,
even a good public speaker,
they weren't born that way.
They just spend a
lot of time doing it.
And it's shocking how
terrified people are of it.
But you all need jobs
at doomed companies
to just get over it
for a couple years.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, now, now.
You're not making any
predictions about Google there?
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
I don't think you
guys have to worry
too much about Google.
You guys actually, you
wouldn't show me the room,
but there is a room that
literally prints money here.
I'm not allowed to see it.
MALE SPEAKER: Shh.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Not
allowed to see it.
But I know that.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
a Google X thing.
We don't talk about that.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I see.
All right.
MALE SPEAKER: So
speaking of companies
that were not doomed, another
big section of the book
is about Reddit,
which of course, you
were one of the founders of.
And it's really striking
to me in reading the book,
you tell the story.
And of course,
you tell the story
about how your Y
Combinator experience was
really pivotal to that.
But the Y Combinator
connection comes back
in almost every chapter
of the book that follows.
I'm sort of curious,
one, what do
you think about that
community and its value,
not just to your company, but
to the startup scene in general?
And then maybe a
harder question.
If that pitch at Y Combinator
had not worked out,
what do you think
would have happened?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Wow.
OK.
Well.
So first and foremost,
Steve and I--
I got to give you
the full thing.
Like, Steve and I
were seniors at UVA.
And I had talked
to him-- basically,
I had an epiphany
at a Waffle House.
Realized that I didn't
want to be a lawyer.
Sorry.
I just--
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
And thankfully, I
realized I wanted to just live
like a college student working
on fun projects.
And I had this friend
of mine, Steve,
who was a talented engineer.
We had talked about
stuff for long enough.
Anyway, I convinced him
to work on a company
with me called My
Mobile Menu, or MMM.
That was the name for it.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING].
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I can
never tell if that's
a good response,
like great idea,
or that was a stupid name.
But anyway, I
convinced him to do
this instead of taking a
job at a software company.
And during our senior
year, his girlfriend
saw an article somewhere
on the interwebs
about a guy named
Paul Graham giving
a talk on how to
start a startup.
And he was up in Boston.
And it was during our
senior year spring break.
So of course, we went to Boston
instead of going to a beach,
because laptops suck on beaches.
There's not a lot to do there.
A lot of screen glare.
It's just not fun.
MALE SPEAKER: Sand.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: And we
heard him give this talk.
There's rarely WiFi.
It's not fun.
And we heard Paul
give this talk.
And we lucked out.
Steve approached him
afterward to get an autograph.
And I followed and
said, it'd totally
be worth the cost of
buying you a drink
to pitch you on our idea.
We came from Virginia.
Like, hear us out.
And he was shocked.
Shocked that, I guess, we
came all the way from Virginia
to Boston, and said OK.
And one thing leads to another.
A few weeks later, he
announces Y Combinator.
He had given us really
good feedback on MMM.
And we applied and
had a great interview,
and then got rejected.
And then got drunk.
And the next morning,
he called back--
MALE SPEAKER: It's good
that it went in that order.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Right.
We would have known
the exact reason
why wed gotten rejected if we
had just gotten drunk first.
It would have made the
interview more fun, but it hurt.
It hurt.
And they called us back
the next morning and said,
we don't like your idea.
It's too early.
2005, right, the smartest
phone on the market
was a Treo with a stylus.
Remember those things?
And like, BlackBerry
was still a company.
And I guess Palm was
still a company too.
MALE SPEAKER: What,
no love Newton?
Come on.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Anyway,
it was too early.
Aw.
Another wonderful product.
But like, it was
ahead of its time.
And we lucked out,
because he calls up.
And I'm like, hello?
And Paul says, listen, we'll
let you do Y Combinator.
Just come up with a new idea.
Do something on the web.
Mobile's too early.
So we come back up there.
We speak with Paul for an hour.
He asked what our problems
are every morning.
And we say, a bunch
of things, including
how to find out what's
going on in the world.
And Steve have loved
Slashdot for many years.
I was just reading a bunch
of news sites in my browser
every morning.
And that became what
would become Reddit.
And so, all that's to say Y
Combinator changed our lives.
Even after the success we had
with Reddit, for Steve and Adam
and me to some
extent, it was a no
brainer to do Y
Combinator with Hipmunk.
And look, that's not to say
there's obviously-- everyone
knows about this sort
of Y Combinator mafia
in that network.
We don't do anything
illegal, but it's
that very strong
network among founders.
If nothing else, I
think it is great
because it has helped people
really appreciate how-- they
were the first ones to really
show, if you invest less
money than it costs
to get a Ford Focus,
you can have a billion dollar
company within a few years.
I mean look, no matter how
you feel about Y Combinator,
I think part of reason
it's been so special
is they genuinely care
about founders doing right
by their founders.
And I think that more broadly
helps the greater ecosystem,
because now investors
can't get away
with being jerks in the way that
they used to even 10 years ago.
That founder friendliness
has a ripple effect.
And so, yes, it's influenced.
I'm very appreciative,
because it's made me who I am.
And the reality is, if we
hadn't gotten that call back,
we would have gone
back to Virginia
and tried to prove
Paul and Jessica wrong.
We would have showed them MMM
is going to take over the world.
We probably would've stayed
in Charlottesville, Virginia,
which is a great college town,
but not the biggest market.
And we probably
would have languished
for a few years trying to figure
out what was going to happen.
Maybe we would have
gotten lucky with the app
store finally coming online.
Who knows?
MALE SPEAKER: All I know is
all the college kids at UVA,
they could have had a great
mobile ordering service.
And you just--
ALEXIS OHANIAN: If only.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
it's very disappointing.
It's very disappointing.
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
We abandoned them.
But what is so cool
now is there are so
many companies that
are doing this.
And someone's going
to win the day,
and then we'll never have to
wait in line for a frappuccino.
So there's that.
MALE SPEAKER: So!
One other thing that
comes through to me
as I'm reading the book about,
obviously, you start Reddit,
and then you guys go
on and do Hipmunk,
and you've done a whole bunch
of other great startup-related
ideas, and supported a
lot of other startups,
you're not a technical person,
sort of by your own admission
in the book.
You were not the coding
chops behind Reddit.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Nope.
MALE SPEAKER: And you haven't
been the coding chops behind
any of these other startups
that you've-- so, I'm sort
of curious.
A lot of people in this room
don't have that handicap.
God bless you.
But for those of
us like myself, I
was a liberal arts
major undergrad,
I'm sort of curious, what
are your thoughts about,
is being a technical person
more and more necessary?
Less and less necessary?
Is it orthogonal to the whole
question of being in a startup?
I'm really curious
about your prospective
in a world full of hardcore
coders, not being one.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: You
know, the running
joke in that first
batch of Y Combinator--
and this is back when it
was in Boston, all right,
but it was maybe a dozen
or so companies-- was,
what does Alexis do?
And they'd always ask
this about Steven.
At some point, it was
clear they weren't joking.
They were genuinely concerned.
Because I think I was the only
non-technical person in YC.
Maybe with one exception.
But also, YC's very biased.
This whole tech
industry for startups
is so biased towards
technical founders, which
is why it's so important
to be able to write code.
Because if you have an
idea, congratulations.
You are one of everyone.
Everyone has great ideas.
So it is more
important than ever.
And if I could do it all over
again, I don't want to brag,
but at Howard High School, I
was the best in my Pascal class.
I loved programming.
MALE SPEAKER: And you
knew how to pitch software
in 10 minutes.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I
knew how to pitch.
I had that going for me.
And I was very proud of
my mascot doodles as well.
But at the end of the day, if
I could do it all over again,
I would've stuck with computer
science when I got to college.
What happened was I met
Steve freshman year.
He just lived across
the hall from me.
And I was so excited,
because here's another geek.
He was playing video games.
We were talking about
gaming PCs we had built.
And at some point, he's like
I'm in engineering school.
I do CS.
And I was like, oh,
I think I'm going
to be pre-med or something.
That lasted a week.
I ended up being
a history major.
And it was clear
he was someone--
I feel guilty saying this.
But it was clear, he
was the kind of person
who-- when a talented
or fairly talented
high school athlete goes to
college and meet someone who's
very clearly, you
just know, she's
going to be in the
Olympics one day.
And you think, well, I'm
probably going to ride the pine
and have to figure out
something else to do.
I felt that way
when I met Steve.
Here was someone
who was clearly just
a brilliant technical mind.
He was going to go
off to do things.
And I was intimidated by it.
MALE SPEAKER: He
ruined it for you.
You were like, I'm
not going to do that.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: And the
the first version of Reddit
was in LISP-2.
And he spent a sad 48 hours
trying to work with me.
I was trying to learn
LISP for about 48 hours.
I still have a photo
of that journal entry
where I just said, this
hurts, dot, dot, dot.
That was not fun.
I still can't look
at a parenthesis
without like, shaking
a little to this day.
MALE SPEAKER: I think you're
selling yourself a little bit
short.
Because I think a lot of what
you talk about in the book
is the importance of
figuring out what users want,
and really paying attention,
being there, listening
to their complaints,
answering them.
And the truth of the matter
is I'm guessing Scott probably
didn't have the time to do
as much of that as you did.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yeah.
Steve was busy actually
building the site.
MALE SPEAKER: Steve, rather.
Sorry.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yes.
So what I tell non-technical
founders today?
One, learn how to code.
You can get started right there.
The tutorials that
are available today
versus even eight
years ago when we
started Reddit are orders
of magnitude better.
But if you do manage to
convince a technical co-founder
to work with you, be ego-less.
Be willing to do
anything, whether it's
ordering the takeout,
dealing with the lawyers,
negotiating the cell phone bill.
Like, do everything else.
Create and care so
much especially early
on about those few
users who are actually
willing to try your new service
that no one has ever heard of,
that has a weird typo, and
care so much about them.
Because those people are crazy.
Those people are
amazing and wonderful.
And like, those are
the ones who are
going to be those early
adopters, those evangelists.
I mean, that's how we built
the audience at Reddit.
That's how we did it at Hipmunk.
That's how I see non-technical
founders doing it all time.
But really, I mean, I'm
preaching to the choir here.
But developing and writing
code is the most valuable skill
of the century.
And like I said, if I could
do it all over again, I would.
MALE SPEAKER: So in the
book after the acquisition
of Reddit, you did a whole bunch
of really interesting things
that were not just about
making the next million
dollars or whatnot.
So say a little bit about that.
It struck me that a lot
of the stuff you did
were much more
civic-minded than I
think I'm used seeing-- usually
men who cash out from startups,
I don't see them doing the
kinds of things you did.
And so I'm curious, what
put you on that path?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Oh, wow.
I should probably give
all the credit to my mom.
I don't know.
I mean, I think when you
have the fortune that I had
of being a 23-year-old
millionaire,
you can go one of two ways.
At the end of the day, though,
what anchored me so much
was having the relationship
that I had with both my parents,
but especially my mom,
that made me appreciate
what really mattered in life.
And I won't go into
too much detail
because it usually
makes me sad and cry.
So instead, what I
will say abstractly
is most 22,
23-year-olds, whatever,
they don't have the wisdom that
usually comes with age when you
actually start questioning
your mortality,
and wondering what's
going to happen,
and what you'll care about
when you're on your death bed.
As a 23-year-old, I
knew very, very well
what people cared about
when they were facing death.
And that something I
wish I could, trust me,
I wish I could not
have had that happen.
But the advantage was
it gave me a perspective
that I think usually, we
aren't fortunate enough,
I suppose is the word,
to get until much later.
So all that's to say, it was
easy because I knew that there
were not going to
be-- I never wanted
to have things
that made me happy.
I wanted to have experiences
and actions and a legacy that
made me happy.
And look, I think
altruism is selfish.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not a monk here.
It is an opportunity
for us who have
done so well to make sure
other people can too.
And look, I also say this, you
correctly identified my gender.
But it is also, as a
straight white dude,
the way I like to describe it
is it's kind of like playing
on easy mode.
I played a lot of
video games too.
MALE SPEAKER: No, really?
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
That's not obvious.
And I don't think it in any
way takes away from success
that I'm proud of that
I feel like I've earned.
But it's an
admission of the fact
that it is just a
little easier for things
that are not of my control.
Like, it's the way the
world is, unfortunately.
But it makes me really
aware of the asterisk.
This isn't like a Barry
Bonds kind of asterisk.
But it is an asterisk
that points out
that, yeah, I had advantages
other people don't have.
And if I really believe in
the power of the internet,
it's for anyone with a
great idea to be awesome.
That's why I wrote the book.
That's why I'm going on a
crazy 150 stop bus tour.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, actually,
I was going to just ask.
Say a little bit
about that bus tour.
Because I thought that
was-- for an the industry--
if you read the
tech press, I mean,
I would love to do a study
of every company mentioned
on Tech mapped.
And it would be very
interesting to see
if there was anything
between the West Coast
and the East Coast that is
ever mentioned on TechCrunch.
I don't mean to single them out.
It's true, I think,
of all the tech press.
What made you think, let's go
across the country in a bus?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Well, I think
you're absolutely right.
And you're talking
a guy, mind you--
Reddit was not once
covered in TechCrunch
until the day we got acquired.
I mean, we're based out of
Somerville, Massachusetts.
We're still in a startup hub.
But there is very much,
most of the tech press
stays to the Bay, New
York, Boston, the Coast.
And last year,
this pissed me off,
because I kept hearing
Silicon Valley-- no offense,
guys-- defeated Hollywood in the
battle against SOPA and PIPA.
And it's like, yeah,
OK, you all showed up.
But the whole country showed up.
Millions of people--
MALE SPEAKER: The whole world.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: The
whole world, right?
And so, I wanted to illustrate
this as best I could.
And instead of just talking
about it, we crowd-funded a bus
and drove it through the
Heartland for 10 days.
We visited Google
Fiber in Kansas City,
and took a number
of other stops,
and met with farmers, and
truckers, and startup founders,
and students, and
all kinds of people
who were using the
internet to be awesome.
Whether it was starting
companies, running their family
farms better.
All that to really just
show off that it wasn't just
Silicon Valley.
The internet economy is not
just a few zip codes here
in California.
It's the entire world.
At least for our
politicians' consideration,
it is the entire United States.
Every one of their
constituents lives
in like, a digital district.
And so I thought, all
right, that was fun.
That was my beta test.
Now let's do it for five months
and go to 75 universities.
Because I basically want to
deliver the class or the talk
that I wish I had had while
Steve and I were at UVA.
We lucked out, right?
We heard Paul Graham was giving
a talk in Boston up at Harvard.
We got up there.
But I want to deliver it.
I'm excited, because we're
going to go to Ohio State.
Arizona State, all right?
I don't know how many Arizona
State alums are in the crowd
right now.
Represent.
All right?
So Arizona State
has a reputation
of being the school that
has a very good time.
Would that be accurate?
When we announced
the tour, and we
had all the obvious schools--
and I wanted to make sure
we hit a number
of large schools.
Not just the Ivies.
I went to UVA.
I went to a public school.
But still, not just
the obvious candidates.
Arizona State,
I don't know what they did,
but that came out in droves.
There was a deluge
of emails and tweets
from people at Arizona State.
Undergrads and grads--
MALE SPEAKER: They
heard about MMM,
and they were all like,
we need more of that.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Maybe.
I hope so.
At the very least,
at the very least,
they were pissed off because
they care about this stuff.
They want that spirit
of entrepreneurship,
because it is there in pockets.
But they want someone to
come in really be like,
yes, there's no reason
why you can't do this too.
And it was great.
And I have to admit, even I was
a little surprised at first.
Then I was like,
shut up, Alexis.
Stop being surprised.
If the thesis is true,
this is not just something
that kids at
Stanford care about.
And obviously, it's easy to
just cherrypick and be like,
every kid from Stanford wants to
start her own startup one day.
And that's probably
true, actually.
But more power to them.
But this is a nationwide, this
is a worldwide phenomenon.
And it's not just
starting companies.
It's getting your first
film funded on Kickstarter.
It's opening your
first Etsy store.
It's using these platforms, even
if you're not building them.
MALE SPEAKER: And have
you taken that message
out to other countries as well?
I imagine this is a message
that a lot of people
are ready to hear.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yes.
And it's been funny.
Because of interesting--
I don't know how exactly
the world works with a
publishing and licensing
internationally.
There have been a
number of people abroad
who have had trouble getting
the book because it's
not technically
published there yet,
even in digital form, which
is kind of a mind job.
So they found ways
to acquire the book
on the internet using things.
Which is great.
I'm happy the ideas spread.
And there has been a ton
of requests to go abroad.
But I'll tell you, I feel like
I learn more from those things
than I could possibly present.
One of the stories that
had such a big impact on me
was going to Egypt maybe a
month or so after Mubarak felt.
And it was a tech
entrepreneurship conference.
And here I am in Cairo talking
a few dozen entrepreneurs who
are literally revolutionaries.
Like, they call founders
like me and David Karp, Larry
and Sergey revolutionaries.
That's bullshit.
No offense to those guys.
But like, we're not
revolutionaries.
That's a great hyperbole
to throw in a magazine.
But like, these were people
who were actually trying
to forge a new Egypt,
and in the process
were also starting companies,
and had the same ambitions.
They ask the same
damn questions you
get asked in Brooklyn from
a bunch of tech founders.
It's obviously very
different starting a company
in Egypt versus here for lots
of sort of macro reasons.
But at a micro
level, they're just
trying to make something
people want just the same.
And to see that same kind of
hustle is so inspirational,
because I realize the life
lottery ticket that comes just
from being born in the States
versus being born anywhere
else, and how easy it is to
just open a laptop and get
started on a business.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: So I
think it's a good time
to get to the politics
part of our program today.
Obviously, a chapter of your
book is about the SOPA/PIPA
that you played and Redditors--
ALEXIS OHANIAN: And Google.
Thank you, Google.
MALE SPEAKER: We did our part.
And Wikipedia.
And all kinds of other
folks participated in it.
I'm curious.
What got you interested?
What made it possible when
that happened for you to sort
of say, hey, yeah,
this is something
I want to try to
do something about?
And do you think there
are any real lessons
that you want to impart to
people about what you learned
and what the internet
hopefully learned.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Oh, yes.
So I fell into this.
I had not been terribly
politically active before this.
I mean, I voted, but I was
not by any means an activist,
or any way really that
passionate about it.
And then I got an
email from a friend
of mine, Christina [? Shi ?].
And she said, hey,
some friends of mine
are working on this thing
called Fight for the Future,
and they're really worried about
these two bills, SOPA and PIPA,
and they may
actually become law.
And I took a look.
And I'm reading through
it, and I'm like, no, no.
This is so stupid.
There is no way this
could actually become.
And I start emailing, and
I realized very quickly
that, no, actually, these
bills are considered
to be inevitable,
inevitable, in Washington.
They had Democrats.
MALE SPEAKER: They were wired.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: They
had Republicans.
It was done.
The check was signed.
MALE SPEAKER: It was
like, the Chamber
of Commerce and
the unions agreed.
And they were like, well,
that never happened.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Right.
Let's take advantage, right?
This would be at a time
when, even back then,
I know it's hard to
believe, government
was seemingly dysfunctional.
Back then.
MALE SPEAKER: Compared to what?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Good thing
we got that one solved.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: But
this was something
that was ostensibly bipartisan.
It was.
They had Democrats and
Republicans lining up.
Hollywood, the
entertainment industry,
had dropped about $94
million in lobbying.
It was all finished.
All going to happen.
At the time, I was just
transitioning out of Hipmunk,
and it was clear I'd be
a hypocrite if I didn't
participate, because
Steve and I never
would have been able to start
Reddit if either of those bills
were law.
And don't get me wrong.
I would've loved if
my peers at Facebook,
and Twitter, and everywhere
else were also joining in,
but it's fine.
It's fine.
MALE SPEAKER: We were there.
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
Yes, I know-- no, I
know-- well, dude,
between Google,
and then the Wikipedia
blackout was the big one.
Because that made it-- I was
ignored by even my friends who
are producers in the media
up until Wikipedia went dark.
Because then, top 10 website.
Actually, I remember
checking Wikipedia
at like, five minutes
past midnight,
and I was pissed off
because it was down.
And I was like, oh, no, wait.
Right.
Good cause.
This is a good cause.
MALE SPEAKER: [LAUGHING].
ALEXIS OHANIAN: And I felt
that rage for a minute.
I was like, what's happening?
Oh, right.
But it was after that that
all of a sudden, the phone
starts ringing, and I spend
24 hours pretty much on TV
explaining why the
internet's enraged.
But like, all of this
is to say, like I said,
I got a fortuitous email.
I was down in DC a week later.
And I started meeting
with senators and reps
and their staffers.
And what was so wild was they
were actually listening to me.
The ones we met with, at least.
This is a small sample.
But they were
actually listening.
We would go around the table.
We'd have our three
minute elevator pitch
for saving the internet.
And I just told my
story of Reddit,
and how Steve and I got
this thing started out
of an apartment for $12,000,
and now look what it's doing.
And that story of the American
Dream, that economic story,
was enough to get people
to perk up their ears.
Because look, as sad
as it is, the thing
that actually moves them
is the potential of being
accountable for losing jobs.
MALE SPEAKER: Jobs.
Economic.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Jobs.
Jobs.
I actually went on the
technology subreddit
the night before and
asked for advice.
I said, should I talk
about censorship?
Should I talk about the
economic repercussions?
And it was great.
I was getting talking
points from the internet.
And everyone was saying--
MALE SPEAKER: What
could possibly go wrong?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Well, touche.
I lucked out because the
ratio of cats to good advice
was actually pretty good.
Not too many cats.
But they all said, don't
even bother with censorship.
And it was just cynicism.
There were a few
people who claimed
to be staffers or
former [INAUDIBLE] I
said don't even bother.
No one cares.
Talk about the jobs.
Jobs, jobs, jobs.
Mentioned jobs
every two seconds.
Jobs.
MALE SPEAKER: You
mentioned in the book--
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Jobs.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
Jobs.
The protest in New York
that you attended in person.
The fact that one of the
things you said-- I mean,
there's a whole
bunch of people who
came out in IRL to
protest against this.
And you asked mostly techies,
I assume, how many of you
work at companies
that are hiring?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yeah.
Every hand.
MALE SPEAKER: And I
thought that was great.
Very powerful.
And that's exactly what people
in DC can hear, for better
or for worse.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: And
that message resonated.
And we saw a bill that went
from inevitable to unthinkable,
almost overnight.
After the blackout on the
18th, you saw people running.
Running, because a bunch of
citizens picked up a phone,
called up.
A bunch citizens
signed petitions.
A bunch of citizens
actually got engaged.
And millions of
disparate people-- this
was a leader full movement.
It wasn't just a couple
people pulling strings.
This was a decentralized,
very internet kind of story.
And it worked.
It actually worked.
It did something that everyone
in DC said was not possible,
and it defeated an
entrenched lobbying group
that has spent their entire
industry basically trying
to buy Washington to
write laws to preserve
their outdated business models.
I'm a little biased.
But we actually won.
And so for me as a kind
of political virgin,
that was so dangerous, because
it inspired me so much.
Because I was like, holy shit.
Like, the system's broken
99% of the time, but look,
it actually worked.
And it was thanks
to the internet
that we were able to
connect and amass this.
MALE SPEAKER: I
was really struck.
As part of that fight, as people
talk about it in retrospect
now, there is almost a
sense of magic about,
and then there was a blackout,
and then the law was defeated.
But there's been a lot
of great stuff being
written about actually
what happened.
And one of the things that I
think people shouldn't forget
is Tumblr.
Tumblr, early on, they
did an interesting--
they blacked out pieces
of their website.
And then they created, basically
hacking together existing web
tools, they hacked
together a web
to phone interface
that led straight
to the congressional switchboard
of your member of Congress.
And I thought that was just such
a great concrete example of,
it's not magic.
It's existing web tools,
bringing the technologies
of the web, and just tying stuff
together to make things happen.
And Tumblr wasn't
the end of the story,
but I think it was a
very important beginning
to the story that led to
the Wikipedia blackout,
and Google's partial
blackout, and all that.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: The
impressive thing,
and the thing that
I hope to impart on
as many people as
possible, is that we all
have a responsibility.
And I think, just
as citizens, it
is so easy to get so cynical.
It is so easy to get so
disappointed and frustrated.
But we have--
MALE SPEAKER: Again,
this week in particular.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Trust
me, I'm just like,
face-palming most the time
whenever I get updates,
about what's going
on in Washington.
It is still our government.
It is still a government by
the people, for the people.
And the internet presents--
it is just a tool--
but it presents a tool that can
be used to let us actually get
the leverage and
input that we deserve.
That we've always deserved.
That we always should have had.
And so that part of that
is just being-- I mean,
I go around demoing the contact
Congress app on my smartphone,
just because I like
the accessibility.
I've been calling my rep
staff the last couple weeks
just to check in.
Like, I like the
accessibility of knowing
that I can push a button--
MALE SPEAKER: Government
going to go back online?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Just be
like, hey, what's happening?
Like, we should feel that
same kind of accountability.
Because so much of
the inane stuff,
I can see the photo of
some stranger's breakfast
right now on Instagram,
or what have you.
That's great.
I'm happy that exists.
I'm not going to hate on it.
I like looking at food.
But if we get that kind of
transparency and insight
into random things
about random strangers,
shouldn't we have that kind of
insight into our government?
Into the people
who represent us?
MALE SPEAKER: So
this was the thing
that really struck
me reading your book.
And frankly, even after
the SOPA/PIPA fight.
I agree with you completely.
I mean, that kind
of transparency
is absolutely crucial.
But another piece of it,
frankly, is the money piece.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yes.
Huge part of it.
MALE SPEAKER: And I've
wondered for a long time,
why is there no
Kickstarter for politics?
We've taken the tools
of transparency.
We've taken the tools of
phone calls and all of that.
But we haven't
democratized the tools
of giving money to politicians
when they do things we like.
Because that's
positive reinforcement.
It can be effective.
So that's always struck me.
Why haven't we crowdfunded
the government we want to see?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I don't think
we've had candidates yet
that have really been able to
have the savvy, or the gusto,
or the what.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's
crowd-fund them.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I mean, right?
Like, I mean, there are--
MALE SPEAKER: What are
you doing next fall?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Well,
Google, I wanted
to come here to
announce that next fall,
I am running for nothing.
Here's the thing.
We're going to get a candidate.
And because she's
a technologist,
she's going to
instinctively understand
how valuable this is.
And with that, we're going to
[INAUDIBLE] technologically
right.
Let me go down the list.
OK.
Solved problem is crowdfunding.
This is a solved problem.
Right?
We could do this tomorrow.
We could do this in hackathon
over the next 24 hours.
One of my favorite
examples of a Google Doc,
shameless plug in action,
is the nonprofit watsi.org,
which manages every single
financial transaction
on that nonprofit in a
public, real-time, of course,
Google Doc.
So at any moment, you can go
to this nonprofit's website
and check up on their finances.
Every transaction.
That kind of
transparency is solved.
That's done.
They're doing it right now.
And they're an example
that's probably
going to affect every
nonprofit going forward,
because why else would I want
to give to a non-profit that
doesn't give me that
kind of accountability?
Watsi can do it, why can't you?
We get someone running
for office, crowdfunding.
Actually publicly sharing
every dime of where money gets
spent, where it comes in.
That is already public,
it just comes out too late
in real time.
Then all of a sudden, now
we have a representative
or a senator who we can
point at and say, she did it.
Why the hell can't you?
And have that example as a
very real, concrete-- except
and all this software is
pretty much off the shelf.
Like, I'm spending
the next five months
on a bus just talking
to college students.
But I hope it
inspires some who are
at least-- I guess they'd
have to be old enough to run.
Well, they could do
it at the local level.
The point is, it
is going to happen.
And when it does, I
can't help but feel
like they're going to have such
an amazing amount of support
from all of those
people who called up
to fight against SOPA/PIPA.
All those people who
care about the internet.
The internet public is
just about everyone.
And it's about time we actually
could flex some muscle,
because this is what we deserve.
MALE SPEAKER: So I totally
agree with all of that.
And I look forward
to seeing that.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: We should
find this candidate.
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER:
That's a great idea.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Take it, please.
Someone do it.
MALE SPEAKER: But
let me just say,
I think it's sort of funny.
I mean, in Silicon
Valley, we work at Google,
you read Reddit.
You forget that
outside of this bubble,
the internet actually has a
very different reputation,
if you will.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And I
just wanted to ask you,
so much to the press
about the internet
is dominated by the
bad guys, whether it's
malware people, or revenge porn.
It's like every media cycle
finds some tiny corner
of the internet to say that
this is what the internet is.
And of course,
Reddit, you probably
have more than a fair amount of
experience with this problem.
So I'm sort of curious,
what are your thoughts?
Is this a PR problem?
Is this a real problem?
What, if anything, should
the internet do about it,
or not do about it?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: OK.
Well, so the internet--
in this instance,
when I describe
the internet, I'm
talking about this technology.
The internet is a reflection,
like any other tool,
of the people who
use it, whether it's
a hammer, whether
it's a printing press,
whether it's a thing-- and
whether it was the 5 o'clock
news 30 years ago,
leads and leads,
we have a tendency to
talk about this stuff,
because mundane things
never make headlines.
Joe is a reasonable
person one day.
Jane is a reasonable
person the next day.
That doesn't get attention in
a way that the extremes do.
That's not to say
it's not a problem.
It is just that like all things,
the stuff that is basically
the statistical minority, but
that is doing offensive, awful,
whatever stuff, is the thing
that gets the spotlight.
That gets the attention.
MALE SPEAKER: Unfortunately,
then I worry, then
it gets the laws.
What leads the news becomes the
thing the member of Congress
wants to introduce a law about.
I was just reading a
blog by a law professor
in Santa Clara, Eric
Goldman, who's great.
And he had a great
line this morning.
He said, "I have never
seen any law passed
by any state about
the internet that
has been anything
other than terrible."
And so I wonder, as long
as that's the mechanism,
you see these extreme
stories, and then
that's what yields
policymaker attention,
we have this kind
of-- I wonder if this
is going to be the next thing
the cat signal gets used for.
And I guess that's
my next question.
Where do you think
the next internet cat
signal worthy threat to the
open internet comes from?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: OK.
I mean, Verizon's at it again
with that neutrality stuff.
Or at least thwarting it.
There's TPP, and I
don't think any of us
have a clue what's
going on there,
because it's all closed doors.
World leaders not
telling us jack.
MALE SPEAKER: That's treaty that
will include some copyright law
provisions that will involve a
number of different countries
that are negotiating
it in secret.
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
Totally in secret.
Copyright reform seems
like it's on the table.
That could be great.
I'm hoping it's great.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, I will
say this about copyright form.
That committee of
Congress, they have not
forgotten PIPA and SOPA.
They are still paying
close attention.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Excellent.
MALE SPEAKER: So that's pretty
good, all things considered.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I mean, the
hope there is we can actually
roll back copyright to stop
protecting Mickey Mouse
and actually start
helping people
innovate and be creative.
It's scary.
And I was able to dig up some
old stuff from-- because I went
UVA, of course, I
love quoting TJ.
And I found some
old letters of his
where he even debated
putting an explicit limit
in the Constitution for
personal monopolies.
For copyrights, trademarks.
Because there is a
short-term reason,
and a great reason
to have copyright.
But the way it has been
abused has taken it
so far from its intended
purpose that it's actually
stifling innovation
when it's supposed
to encourage it and enable it.
That's probably
the next one, where
there's going to be some
meeting, something coming up,
and it's going to be on us
to rally as many artists,
as many musicians,
as many authors,
as many creatives,
copyright makers,
as possible to say,
no, no, no, hold on.
Actually, the reason
my buddy-- oh my gosh,
I can only think of
"Dinosaur Comics" right now.
The reason that Ryan North,
who creates "Dinosaur Comics,"
was able to remix
"Hamlet" into a Choose
your Own Adventure
version of "Hamlet"
and raise $600,000
on Kickstarter
was because it's in
the public domain.
I don't think the estate of
Shakespeare loses anything--
MALE SPEAKER: Because
Disney has not yet
made their animated
"Hamlet" version.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I know.
And it's like, we
are so much better
off because it is in
the public domain.
The saddest one is the fact
that Dr. King's speech still
requires some kind of financial
transaction to be viewed.
And it's like, that is
itself an amazing remix
of so many amazing works.
And yes, sadly
enough, here is one
of the most important public
speeches of the 20th century,
and someone needs to be paid
if you want to watch it.
MALE SPEAKER: One of
my favorite stories
is the song "Happy Birthday."
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Right.
The lyrics.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Currently in litigation
with f Music claiming they
own the copyright to that.
now It was just a story about an
online stream of a live event,
where they started
singing "Happy Birthday,"
and the audio got shut down,
because it was like, sorry,
that's a match.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Wow.
Worst birthday ever.
MALE SPEAKER: Anyhow,
I want to leave time
for questions from this
great audience as well.
So if folks have questions, I
think there's a mike somewhere,
so that the video can
hear what you had to say.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much.
I loved what you said about
Y Combinator and the culture
of like startup founders
helping startup founders.
And that's one of
the things that I
see so often on the internet.
When we look at why the
SOPA and PIPA stuff failed
was because there was
just a unified message
and a unified front amongst
the internet citizenry.
How do we continue to take some
of the biting commentary that
comes out of people online, when
we forget that other people are
people buying keyboards?
How do we do that?
How do we foster that spirit?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I wish--
MALE SPEAKER: You mean to say
that unifying YouTube and G+
comments won't solve it?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: No, it will not.
MALE SPEAKER: Inside joke.
Inside joke.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: That's
the reality, right?
I mean, Facebook's
the closest thing
we have to the
realist of identities.
Real name, real photo.
And people still behave
like awful human beings
to people they
know in real life.
I mean, despicable stuff.
So the reality is, I
think no matter what,
some extent of awful people will
feel comfortable saying things
behind the device than
they would in person.
You could make it so
their parents have
to live-stream watch
every comment they type.
Like, there's some subset that
are going to always do that.
So on the one hand,
there's the glib answer
of like, finding a way
to like, electrocute them
whenever-- I mean,
you guys, you,
could maybe plug that
in Android somehow.
Unfortunately, it there is
a certain societal thing
we can do for etiquette
in terms of trying
to encourage that
better behavior.
At some extent, nothing
will be fool-proof.
The gift and the curse to an
open communication platform
is people are open.
Whether they're open to say
things-- because remember,
that same ability
to say something
that you would not
feel comfortable
saying to someone's
face helps someone.
It helps someone say something.
If they live in
a community where
they would be persecuted
for their sexuality,
it gives them the
confidence to say stuff
that they couldn't say with
their real name attached.
Because they might
be persecuted.
That is a great gift.
But the curse of it is, again,
it lets some asshole abuse it.
And I-- only Sith
deal in absolutes.
So I can't say-- you have to
take the good with the bad.
And we need to do as much as
we can to curtail the bad.
And I think a lot
of that's just going
to come from us as a society.
I mean, so much of
this has come up.
And I think specifically
of cyberbullying.
And I think of Louis CK's
recent observation, which
was so spot-on,
in which she said,
the reason I don't let my
daughter's have cell phones,
or really use the
internet much is
because I need
them to understand
that when they are
bullies, it hurts people.
If you bully someone
to their face,
it is a learning opportunity.
And as a kid, usually,
you feel empathy.
You can't really help, unless
you're a total sociopath,
but feel empathy.
But when these kids come
up-- these whippersnappers--
when these kids come
up and can do it
all from the safety of a phone,
they never feel that empathy.
And here's Louis CK on
"The Late Night Show."
And I'm like, damn, Louis.
You've nailed it.
I don't have a solution
yet, but it is very clear
that this is a risk that we run.
Look, you guys are Google
you can figure it out
probably faster than I can.
But it's a real issue.
Because we don't know.
This is all new territory.
The best thing we have going
for us right now is this
is all a new frontier.
And in a lot of ways we,
especially the people
here at Google,
have an opportunity
to sort of guide that
in some way, shape,
or form, whether through the
technology that we build,
or the things we do.
But to some extent, we also
have to accept the fact
that we can't
totally control it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have a question towards
your history major.
You mentioned Jefferson.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Any other figures, or
maybe even trends historically,
or time periods, or
things like that,
that really influenced
your career?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Woah.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Woah, deep.
Oh, man.
I do not get asked
this question.
All right.
I need to make my
history professors proud.
Uh, man.
One of the things that has
really and tru-- well, OK.
When I think of the
future of media,
I am so-- well actually,
let's back this up.
Tim Wu wrote amazing book
called "The Master Switch."
And it's a great
pairing with my book,
because this is real
talk from Professor Wu.
He's just like, listen,
all the same shit Alexis
is saying about the internet
they were saying about radio,
about film, about TV, about
all these other communication
platforms.
And it was going to be so
democratizing, and so amazing,
and so wonderful.
And every single one of them,
every single one of them,
whether it's through big
business, big government,
or some combination
of the two, have
been what they are today, which
is anything but democratic.
So I am very, very cognizant.
I keep that book like,
floating in my head.
As optimistic as I am,
there is a very real chance
that this ends up going
the same way of all
those other platforms.
And humans are resourceful.
There's going to be some
other iteration of it.
But I don't even want
to go down that road.
Because right now, we
have such an opportunity.
It is the world's
largest library,
and the world's
largest stage in one.
And it's accessible to anyone
with an internet connection.
Which is part of the
reason why I love you guys
doing this balloon
internet thing.
Awesome.
Like, access is still
a huge part of it.
And there's some author
who wrote a book that's
saying Google was
making us stupid.
Can't remember who it was.
Very link bait-y title.
Yes, I don't mind
as a history major
not really remembering
that the Civil War was
from 1861 to 1865,
even though it was,
and having to Google that later.
Because yes, that is a cost.
Maybe I'm a little dumber
because I don't remember
that particular
fact, because I know
I can Google it, or Bing it.
[LAUGHTER]
But again, that's the curse.
The gift is anyone with
an internet connection
can now get the world's
knowledge about the Civil War
at their fingertips for nothing.
My trade-off?
That's totally worth.
I will gladly be a little
worse at trivia night
if it means the world can get
access to knowledge that's
historically been only
accessible to those who
had the power, the money, or the
connections, or the whatever.
And again, it's always
a gift and a curse.
There's always, I think
generally speaking,
with any of these
new technologies,
it's always there.
But that is the thing.
And this one feels like
it's going to be different.
I know a lot of
people in tech have
gotten in trouble saying that.
But I really hope so, because
in just the last five years,
it feels like we are on
the cusp of really doing
something special.
And hopefully,
not following suit
and following in the path of
all those other technologies
before it.
Because that would suck.
That would really, really suck.
So let's not screw
this up, people, OK?
OK
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So you said that your
time at Y Combinator
had a huge influence
on your success,
and you think that it's a great
opportunity for young people
to get involved in
the startup industry.
If you look statistically
at the type of people
that are in Y
Combinator, it tends
to be overwhelmingly male,
overwhelmingly white,
overwhelmingly middle
to upper middle class.
How do suggest bringing
that kind of opportunity
to join the startup industry
to people that have generally
been disadvantaged,
like minorities,
women, that kind of people?
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Well,
so the only asterisk
I put on that is we
actually-- I don't
have the numbers in front of me.
But typically, Southeast
Asians also do well at YC.
But yes, definitely
majority male, and still. .
And this is an issue
for Y Combinator.
This is an issue for tech.
And where does it begin?
I mean, the short
answer is, it is largely
a reflection of the applicant
pool to Y Combinator.
So, all right.
How do we broaden
that applicant pool?
I hope visiting 75 universities
brings more people,
like a dose of what is possible.
And at the end of
the day, I don't
care if they apply
to Y Combinator.
I just want them to get
interested in building tech.
But this is such a big problem.
Because the bias
for tech investors
is to invest in founders who
aren't themselves technical.
And so you are looking
at fixing and correcting
what has been a problem
for a very long time.
And so part of it is attacking
it at the early stages, where
it's like, the reason I'm on the
advisor board of [INAUDIBLE],
and I'm actually fund-raising
for every STEM classroom
in Brooklyn right now, is
because it's getting access
to technology in classrooms
for kids at a very young age.
It is increasing the number
of women and people of color
who are doing STEM who are
interested in computer science.
They are amazing
organizations that I support,
like Black Girls Who Code, that
are doing a great job better.
That have single-minded focus
on bringing women of color
into technology and
teaching them how to code.
There are so many
elements to it.
And I mean, from the tech
community's standpoint,
there is also kind
of a responsibility
that we all have to create an
environment and a place that
is just welcoming.
And I don't know whether it
is conduct at hackathons,
whether it is the
kinds of events we run,
whether it's the people
we have on stage.
I mean, it's all of this stuff.
It's a ton of stuff.
And I'm sure there's more
that I could be doing.
But the low-hanging
fruit that I've
been able to find myself most
effective with sort of breaks
down to like, again,
whether supporting classroom
[INAUDIBLE], whether it's
helping organizations that
are specifically
geared towards-- Girls
Who Code is another great one.
Geared towards actually getting
these valuable, valuable skills
in the hands of the
people who need it most,
as well as just sort of
generally trying to be an ally.
But it's not
something that's going
to unfortunately
change overnight.
But I can already
see an improvement
versus eight years ago when
we were starting in tech.
So it's not a reason
to get complacent,
but it's a reason to
feel good about it.
I mean, I was so pleased.
The last Google science
fair thing you guys
do with all the high
schools, I don't
think there was a
single dude finalist.
And that's like, awesome.
Sorry, guys.
But like, it's things like
that, and stories and examples
like that that I think will
hope to show and work on this.
But like, it's far
from overnight.
AUDIENCE: So, it was
kind of interesting.
There was another talk
just before yours.
And it's an editor
from "The Economist"
who's writing a book.
The book is called "The
Writing on the Wall,"
saying that this
version of new media
is actually kind of
old media as well.
And how in the past,
Romans especially, they
used to share information,
and transmission
was relatively
cheap, because you
had people that could transcribe
it, and copy it, and send it
around.
And so, he was actually
like, arguing the fact
that the establishment as
it was before the internet
is kind of the fad.
And that this thing about
being able to share information
more freely is the way things
were done before the barriers
to entry became so large
that people couldn't do it.
So I guess there's kind of
like, some hope for-- like,
you're saying to be
optimistic about,
that is where things are going.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yes.
And I actually bumped into
him in Portland, actually.
And I was able to get a
signed copy of his book.
So I'm a chapter in,
and I know exactly what
you're talking about
about ancient Rome.
What's so cool is, yes--
and it's really easy
to gush about how
great the internet is.
All of those things that
have been so successful
really are just better scaled
versions of things humans
have always done.
Whether it's social media.
I mean, crowdfunding, right?
As soon as we had currency,
actually people were bartering.
They were probably
like, hey, let's all
pitch in to go
create this thing.
Some of the best
ideas are the ones
that are just highly
scaled versions of things
human beings have
always done, instead
of having to teach
us a new skill.
MALE SPEAKER: And on that same
note, I'd encourage any of you,
the next time you're going to
complain about Reddit trolls
or the quality of
YouTube comments,
there's a great article online--
I'm sure you can find it using
your favorite search engine--
about the graffiti in like
Vesuvius--
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Yeah.
Awful stuff on those walls.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
It really is.
People are the same.
It's scaled, but the
people are still the same
as they were then.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Let me,
because it's again, always
very helpful.
One of the things that makes
me so much happier is, so yes,
people always been the same.
And we can get all
deep about like,
the duality of man and humans
and the range of stuff.
But look, I think
historically, we've
always had forces that
have always tried to,
for whatever reasons, whether
they were businesses trying
to sell us more toothpaste,
whether they were governments
trying to make a scared,
whatever, we've always
been pushed toward sort
of fearing our neighbor
and being more afraid
and being worried.
I really do believe most people
are actually pretty decent.
They're just decent people.
And the fact that these stories,
these sort of benign stories,
can now scale a
lot further, when
you can read the story
of some cute kids
in LA Children's Hospital
putting up a sign that
says "Send Pizza," and that can
go around the world, and all
of a sudden, a bunch
of random strangers
are just buying pizza for a
bunch of kids in a chemo ward.
And that story now doesn't
just stay within the family.
I'm sure at some point in
the history of hospitals, ,
someone did some random kind
gesture like buy some pizza
for some sick kids.
But now that story scales.
And now that story gets
seen by more people,
and more people actually
go, oh, you know what?
That's kind of nice.
Like, that's cool.
And we can actually finally
start scaling those subtle,
kind gestures of humanity that
never would have made headlines
before.
That never would
have gone beyond
our initial social circle.
Again, I am optimistic.
But I really hope we get a
little closer to all realizing
we're all just
carbon-based lifeforms
trying to get by on
a little blue dot.
At least until the singularly.
And I saw Kurzweil earlier.
That's going to be amazing.
But until then, we got to try
not to fuck this thing up.
MALE SPEAKER: As they said
in "Star Trek," "Ugly Bag
of Mostly Water."
AUDIENCE: With all
the revelations
of what the NSA has been doing
to spy on a bunch of people,
I was kind of wondering-- sorry.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: I was
like, is that God?
AUDIENCE: I was
kind of wondering
what your thoughts on that were?
I know a lot of politicians seem
to be OK and in support of it.
I can kind of guess
what your thoughts are.
But two, also, how do you feel
that the internet may change
in response to this information?
And also three, if
there's anything
you think we could do to
prevent any bad outcomes that
might come of it?
For example, you hear
about Brazil and China
talking about
decentralizing the internet.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Oh, man.
All right.
Well, NSA.
Yeah.
What is creepy, like
there's a brief dystopian
section of the book
where I'm like,
here's what's going to
happen if we fuck this up.
And.
I joke about
everything the NSA has
been doing for the last few
years, which was awkward.
Because I didn't want
that to be prophetic.
That is incredibly
upsetting to me.
And I think more
and more Americans
are realizing that-- maybe
this is again wishful thinking.
But we have a Fourth
Amendment that
protects our right to
privacy in [? meet ?] space.
Right?
Our mail.
Our home.
If you want to see it,
great, it's due process.
Let's get a warrant.
That should also apply
to our digital email,
or our digital mail,
and our digital space.
And I hope we can connect
those dots for politicians,
so that they realize that one,
that boundary needs to exist.
Absolutely.
Full stop.
And then we can actually have an
honest, open, public discussion
about how much it's all a
trade-off between security
and privacy.
And last I checked, this is
ostensibly still a democracy.
We should have
discussions about this.
We should be able
to publicly make
decisions about just
how much privacy
we're willing to give up
in the name of security.
And so far, not only, we haven't
had those discussions at all.
It's been a total cluster.
It's violated all of
our rights to privacy.
And we are coming up on the 12
year anniversary of the Patriot
Act in a few weeks.
And as a nation, we were
really worried, really
scared, and made some
decisions that I think now
12 years later, now that
we can all catch our breath
and look at, were not in the
best interests of our rights
as citizens.
And I hope we can look
back at those things now.
I mean, that was a Republican
President, George W. Bush
that signed that
into law, and then
a Democrat who has upheld them.
And so, everyone
of us, regardless
of our political
stripes, I believe,
is really starting to
look critically at this.
And I hope we get
that line drawn.
Because we need it.
Because we shouldn't
have CEOs having
to deal with these
requests when they're not
actually in the spirit
of the Constitution.
So I am encouraged by the
fact that humans are always
resourceful.
Like, every now and then, I see
the Darknet thread bubble up,
where people are
like, it's cool,
we're going to make
our an internet again.
Long-term, I know
humans are resourceful.
It doesn't matter.
Right now, how much time
and money and energy
does the Chinese
government spend
trying to keep people
from looking at photos
of the Tenement Square Massacre?
And yet still, every
day, people thanks to Tor
and other pieces of software,
look at those things.
We are very resourceful.
And that in the
end gives me hope.
I just don't want it to
have to come to that.
And so in the meantime,
again, it comes back to us
being active citizens, and
actually using this government
that in theory represents us
to not be stupid, and actually
have technologists in the room.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I've really enjoyed seeing
your work on "The Verge" with--
ALEXIS OHANIAN: "Small Empires."
AUDIENCE: --"Small Empires."
It's awesome.
So I want to know
how that's going on,
and where you're
going with that?
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
So "Small Empires"
is a show that I
do on "The Verge"
to basically highlight
New York tech.
And not just show
off the founders,
because everyone
gets to see founders.
Show off people who work there.
And.
More interestingly to me,
people who use these platforms.
In my way, it's like
startup propaganda.
I want people to watch it
and be entertained and think,
holy shit.
Not only can I start
one of these things,
I could work there.
And I can even use this thing.
I'm a poet, and I can use rap
genius to annotate my art.
That's an actual example.
And also, of course, show
off the New York tech scene.
So we have part
two of season one
that just launched on Tuesday.
It's going to continue through--
we've got six episodes up now.
The OKCupid one
might be my favorite.
It just went up.
The couple on that episode will
make you feel so unromantic.
Every one of you
is going to feel
like you need to
step up your romance
game after seeing that episode.
Mark my words.
But what do I hope?
I hope it scales.
I hope we can get it on,
I don't know, Netflix,
so we get it somewhere were
a bunch more people can even
see it.
And a lot of people have
said, hey, come to Victoria
and do a "Small Empires" here.
Come to Orlando and do
a "Small Empires" here.
And you know what I said?
I love traveling, but I
cannot possibly do all that.
I'm on a bus for the
next five months.
So one of the things
we're trying to do,
and I don't think
it's been done before,
is I'd like to open
source the show,
or license out the
show to some extent.
Kind of like how TED does TEDx.
I want someone to be
like, hey, listen.
I want to run the show in
Victoria, British Columbia.
Because we've got an
amazing startup community.
We're building "Small Empires."
I want to show it off.
And I'll be like, cool.
Here's what you need.
Go forth and make awesome stuff.
And like, some basic
branding guidelines.
Here's how you
shoot the episode.
This isn't rocket science.
It's three cameras. .
Four really talented people
do all the real work.
And I just sit there
and talk to people.
Like, it can be run
for pretty cheap.
And I would love to see
"Small Empires" sprout
all over the world.
Because I want these
ideas to spread.
I could spend a lot
of time on planes
and go to a bunch of
different communities
all over the country.
But like, I want to see "Small
Empires, Nairobi" from someone
who actually loves Nairobi
as much as I love New York.
Because like, I
can love Nairobi,
but not in the same
way I love New York.
And like, let's let locals
show off their communities
that they're proud off.
Because to hell
with what I think.
MALE SPEAKER:
Solutions that scale.
We at Google care a
little bit about that.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Is
Google going to help me
with "Small Empires?"
AUDIENCE: I'm from
Orlando, so sign me up.
MALE SPEAKER: There you go.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: That was
not a hypothetical either.
Stay tuned, man. "Small
Empires, Orlando."
And I was shocked too.
I was like, really?
Orlando?
And he was like, yeah, man.
We're doing shit.
It's not just Disney.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was kind of
interested on what technologies
you think are going to continue
help the growth of kind
of like, an open internet?
I saw the post by
Shriner yesterday
about Aaron Swartz'
software finally shipped
for a secure Dropbox.
And I used to work
for iFixit, and all
of their commentary
with press now,
like the press is
actually requiring
that they use PGP on
like, all of their emails,
which is pretty intense.
I mean, they're tech reporters
but I figure that can spread.
So I'm kind of curious.
PGP's old, SecureDrop's new.
And I'm kind of curious like, in
the next five years, what kind
of technology do we need
to keep in open internet?
I mean, there's
the Darknet stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: Say
the word Tor again.
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
Tor, Tor, Tor, Tor.
Wow.
Here's what I love.
The nature of
innovation is I actually
don't have a fucking clue.
I don't know.
It seems to me that, yes, secure
file storage, secure mail,
this whole Lavabit fiasco,
there is clearly even
from a business
standpoint, I think
there's going to be
an increased demand
in an actual secure
messaging system.
There's going to
be increased demand
for an actually
secure storage system.
And it sounds like we're
working towards getting that.
I would hate to see a sort of
Balkanization that comes out
of the internet because of this.
Just even the
standpoint of like,
there are going to be
people who are going
to look twice at
using a service.
Let's say it's an
American company who's
servers are here in the States.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's say.
ALEXIS OHANIAN: That's
terrifying to me.
If I'm putting on
my businessman hat,
I'm like, that's terrifying.
We lead the world, essentially,
in the internet economy.
Like, the world is using Google.
I generalizing here.
But like, there are
not a lot of industries
left where the United States
is sort of king of the roost.
And that is not guaranteed.
It is not guaranteed
in any industry,
but especially one that
is as competitive and fast
to grow as the
internet, as online.
And I worry that if we
aren't building these things
ourselves, someone else will.
And before long, the
next big thing pops up,
and it's in Rakovic, or it's
in Berlin, or go down the list,
where the laws are there that
uphold the kind of privacy
rights that I wish
we had in the States.
Well, that we ostensibly
do have in the States,
but aren't actually
being enforced.
So, yeah.
There are business
opportunities here.
And you guys are
lots of smart people.
I say, I hope my book
does not necessarily
inspire you to go leave
Google and start a company.
Because you guys have
been such wonderful hosts.
MALE SPEAKER: I was
looking in here.
I seem to remember a line in
here about the only people
to go to Google are--
ALEXIS OHANIAN: Are waiting
until they get the right idea
to go start a startup.
That's what they are.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: I have to
give a little background
for this question, so I'll try
not to take up too much time.
Early last year,
I was in college.
I just graduated from
Brown University.
And someone I new named Sunil
Tripathi had disappeared.
And no one knew if he
had committed suicide.
No one knew if he was kidnapped.
No one really had known
what happened to him.
So take a step like,
a couple months
to April, when the Boston
Marathon bombings happened.
So no one had found this
missing student at Brown.
And Reddit led this massive
manhunt to try-- well,
there was a massive
manhunt around the country
to find the Boston
Marathon Bomber.
There was chaos everywhere,
and Reddit had kind of
formed this mob mentality, where
they thought that this missing
student from Brown was one of
the Boston Marathon bombers.
And I was at the
college at the time,
so I saw like the real,
direct harm it was causing.
His family was shattered.
I wasn't particularly close with
him, but I knew his girlfriend.
And she was just, I don't know.
She was just completely
stunned by the whole ordeal.
But this is the background
for my question.
Various forms of media have
always had checks and balances
for free speech, like
print media, like libel.
You can't print
libelous information.
Right?
So I guess, how do
you mitigate the power
of the open, free
internet with its ability
to do harm to people?
ALEXIS OHANIAN:
Traditional media
has gotten it wrong in the past.
I mean, even after the
Navy Yard shooting,
CBS and NBC
misidentified someone
who was involved in the attack.
This is to say, humans are
themselves the problem,
whether they are trained
professional journalists
or not.
There is no good
answer for this.
Because yes, there was
a particular subreddit
which had maybe 1,000
people using it that
was responding to an FBI
request to help track the Boston
bombers.
And they misidentified someone.
"The New York Times" did a
very thorough investigation
in the Sunday magazine
about what happened.
And it turned out
that a journalist
had tweeted that Reddit post.
A journalist, a professional
journalist, had tweeted it out.
And then, it got re-tweeted.
Even Perez Hilton joined in.
And that spun it out of control.
So there are lots of humans
responsible for this.
And at the end of
the day, there just
is not an easy answer for this.
If one journalist draws
attention to a random Reddit
thread, and it gets picked up,
and "The New York Post" decides
to put it on their front
page, how after the fact can
we actually say, what--
and this goes back
to being the gift and the
curse of the open platform.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
ALEXIS OHANIAN: It's an awful,
awful thing that happened.
And unfortunately,
there's no easy solution
for the next time.
I mean, every one of
those trained journalists,
even the one who re-tweeted
that Reddit thread may
make mistakes.
And now we've given an
opportunity for anyone
with a connection
to have a soapbox.
And they're going
to make mistakes.
And so in response,
Reddit has sort of
to the best of its
ability now sort of said,
no more of these
kinds of witch hunts.
You can't create a subreddit to
try to identify the Navy Yard
shooter, or any other person
who the FBI or someone wants
to track down.
But the reality is, they'll
just do it on Twitter.
Right?
That's what happened during
the Navy Yard shooting.
They just do it all on Twitter.
And people are unfortunately,
as they have always
been, capable of
being, even when
they have the best of
intentions, being wrong.
And it is a challenge
that will always
exist as long as we have people.
And once we have
sentient robots,
they'll just enslave us.
So like, I don't know.
There's no easy answer.
I'm happy with
response Reddit took.
But I just know that in a world
with social media, whether it's
a journalist or
Joe Six-pack, it's
probably going to happen again.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Well, I wanted to say thanks.
Thanks a bunch for coming.
And once again, plug the book.
Go read it.
It's available right over there.
And thank you, Alexis,
for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]